the sounds of a bazooky to go with
typical local food a picture postcard
holiday in greece these tourists came
despite the crisis what better than
enjoying summer sun aboard a ferry on
the mediterranean sea
so we're going to greece for holiday
even though there's an economic trouble
there's a lot of beautiful things in
greece and so we're just going to go
help them out
foreign visitors have never been so
valuable tourism is the only sector of
the greek economy prospering at least
for now
the country has one guaranteed magnet
for tourists its beaches fortunately
there haven't been any mass
cancellations by the major tour
operators and chilling on a deck chair
has become an almost political act
we have to support the greek people so
we are staying there full time
behind the scenes the industry is
working flat out to accommodate its
guests marius caloidas company bakes
pita bread round the clock vacationers
want to eat as well as lounge around in
the sun all day that creates jobs and
revenue just what the country so
urgently needs
it's the high season in catering june
july and august are the three months
that feed the rest of the year
all the business strategies supplies and
plans in tourism and catering revolve
around these three months
a sudden wave of cancellations would be
catastrophic something that could happen
if violent unrest were to erupt
alexander arapakis runs a hotel in
athens city center it has a spectacular
view of the acropolis but the business
outlook is rather more worrying
he says a stable economic environment is
absolutely paramount
any other discussion as far as the rates
rates increase the vat i i think it's uh
at least at this moment um is uh
comes second or third
but it's still too soon to say if the
greek crisis will ease
and even if there are no mass
cancellations yet businesses are still
suffering no matter how beautiful
greece's beaches are this year's last
minute bookings are 40
down on the same time in 2014